[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'arrive pas à croire qu'un être
humain ait pu délibérément allumé
l'incendié du cirque ambulant denis
terroir la ville jumelle de rio vous en
offline 2500 spectateurs
on reste sans voix devant le bilan de
cette catastrophe sans précédent qui en
quelques minutes a accumulé 360 cadavres
pour la plupart des corps d'enfants sans
discontinuer des volontaires ont apporté
leur sens aux hôpitaux on a multiplié
les transfusions né des 600 blessés
atrocement brûlés combien pourront être
sauvés
au milieu du terrain vague de cinq
goncalo il ne reste maintenant que des
débris carbonisés le grand bain qui
s'est abattue sur la foule le tunnel de
la ménagerie et parmi tous là les fauves
dont la fuite éperdue avait accru
l'ampleur de la tragédie
les éléphants qui ont déchiré la toile
du cirque avait au contraire sauvé des
centaines de malheureux et la girafe qui
tenait la piste au moment du drame la
plus horrible des tragédies
[Musique]
à paris en dépit de l'interdiction de
toute manifestation sur la voie publique
est dictée par le gouvernement certains
syndicats et groupements de gauche
avaient maintenu leur mot d'ordre de
manifestation anti os le défilé de la
bastille à l'hôtel de ville quinze mille
participants dit la préfecture de police
60000 disent les organisateurs lui donc
lieu comme prévu mais il fut marquée par
de violentes bagarres
bil'in de la manifestation plus de 100
blessés
[Musique]
1961 aura été l'année du cosmos le tour
de la terre de gagarine d'abord
l'exploit de titeuf ensuite qui reste à
25 heures dans les espaces theiler ont
donné à l'urss la gloire d'avoir la
première envoyer un homme dans le ciel
[Applaudissements]
on la première fois des yeux humains ont
pu voir à travers le hublot de la
capsule la terre rouler dans l'infini
pour la première fois des êtres humains
seront détachés de la pesanteur originel
accomplir ce voyage vertigineux dont
l'idée depuis des siècles trouble les
rêves de l'humanité
et après les deux soviétique deux
américain alan shepard et virgil grissom
ont fait à leur tour le grand bond dans
l'espace
1961 l'année du cosmos m revenons sur
terre aux états unis john kennedy
démocrate et catholique a succédé
einsenhower républicain et protestants
au brésil quadros a succédé à kubitschek
à la présidence il a depuis abandonné
son fauteuil
au maroc le roi mohamed 5 a succombé à
la suite d'une opération et son fils est
né sous le nom de race and de hassen la
couronne
[Musique]
en angleterre la princesse margaret a eu
un fils cinquième dans l'ordre de
succession au trône par contre
l'angleterre a perdu un dominion
l'afrique du sud
son leader le docteur verwaerde a
annoncé le retrait de son pays à la
réunion du commonwealth
fidel castro à cuba a résisté
victorieusement à l'assaut des
anticastristes portant un coup sérieux à
la propagande américaine
au congo lumumba prisonnier de ses
adversaires à trouver la mort dans des
conditions mal éclaircies ce qui a
provoqué deux parlements des mêmes à
l'onu une agitation tout à fait tina
coutumes et dans ce temple général
mangou et à des discussions plus
académique l'action de l'onu au congo
même d'ailleurs n'a pas semblé
particulièrement pacificatrice les
casques bleus se sont heurtés à une
résistance qui a très vite dégénéré un
authentique combat dans cette réparation
congolaise qui dure toujours monsieur da
gama celle de secrétaire général des
nations unies a trouvé la mort à bord de
son avion qui s'est écrasé dans la
brousse
à
un autre foyer d'incendié s'est allumé
l'angola où les portugais ont réduit la
révolte qui partie justement du congo
tentaient de s'étaler sur le pays
enfin berlin sur la ligne de démarcation
l'est et l'ouest s'affrontent depuis que
le gouvernement de bangkok a fait élever
ce que les berlinois de l'ouest nomme le
mur de la honte
iceman l'assassin de millions de juifs
récupéré par israël est passé en
jugement mais la sentence de mort qui a
été prononcée est elle bien une peine
pour un tel crime
en france le référendum sur le sort de
l'algérie a approuvé les initiatives du
général de gaulle par une très forte
majorité mais le 22 avril suivant un
putsch éclatent à alger
paris s'est préparée à résister à une
action de force et les rues nocturnes
ont pris un petit air d'état de siège
à ce moment à alger aux cris d' algérie
française la foule a clamé les quatre
généraux qui avait pris la tête du
mouvement de rébellion contre le
gouvernement
mais la fermeté du général de gaulle
devait en quelques jours réprimer le
soulèvement et rendre le calme au pays
ce retour au calme n'est pas allé sans
incident et sur la route de colombey les
deux églises un attentat faillit bien
coûté la vie au président de la
république qui échappe à part une sorte
de miracle
le problème de l'algérie avait fait
quelques pas en avant si la conférence
de lugrin après celle des liens avec
jacques du côté français et belkacem
krim du côté fln n'avait pas apporté de
conclusion on peut croire qu'elles ont
préparé une solution
du côté de be there un coup de tonnerre
la base française de bizerte s'était
trouvée soudain par la seule volonté de
monsieur bourguiba comme assiégée
il fallut devrait condat pour dégager
les accès et rendre à la base sa liberté
drano stupide déclenchée sans raison qui
avait fait 700 morts
chez les paysans un grand mécontentement
trop longtemps alimenté par les
mauvaises conditions du marché éclatait
en violences la bretagne forcé de jeter
ses choux fleurs et ses artichauts faute
de les vendre à des prix rentable
manifesté sa mauvaise humeur ces
barrages de tracteurs sur les routes
faut cette école il devait dans les
semaines suivantes se multiplier dans
diverses régions
et
par contre les fêtes de l'indépendance
célébrée à dakar marquée entre 13 autres
manifestations semblables le succès de
la générosité française
paris recevait de nombreux autres
souverains ou chef d'état il avait
acclamé le roi des belges et la reine
fabiola
et la visite du chah d'iran et de
l'impératrice farah naguère étudiants au
quartier latin faisait frémir toutes les
curiosités et battre tous les cas
là
du côté sportif les succès répétés de
guy périllat dans les grandes épreuves
de ski internationale ramené en france
dès lors y est enviée
dans un autre domaine l'apparition du
twist avait fait l'effet d'un
raz-de-marée
et depuis un certain dimanche les bancs
du palais des sports en savent quelque
chose
le goût de l'art pictural a fait un bond
en avant presque aussi important des
monte-en-l'air de bon goût avec quelques
autres collections dévalisé le musée
d'aix et laissés vides les cimaises
dans le même temps à new york un
rembrandt a battu tous les records de
prix jamais atteint pour un tableau 1
milliards 150 millions d'anciens francs
enfin diverses inventions sont venus
cette année agrémenter la vie courante
du changement instantanée de caractère
dans les machines à écrire mon batteur
de tapis automatique et aux soldats
volant à moteur individuel
que de progrès qui vont faire de notre
temps un paradis terrestre
il ya quand même plus sérieux la france
et l'angleterre pense pas construire un
fond sur la manche qui à 70 mètres
au-dessus de la mer donnera passage aux
chemins de fer et aux autoroutes
l'unesco à adopter pour sauver les
temples d'abou simbel menacé de mort par
le barrage d'assouan l'idée de surélever
d'un seul bloc le temple tout entier au
futur niveau des eaux
à orly la nouvelle aérogare la plus
moderne sinon la plus importante du
monde est entré en service par les
d'acier d'aluminium et de verre
ses dimensions et ses installations
laisse loin derrière elle tout ce qui
existait jusqu'ici en europe
enfin le paquebot france le plus rapide
et le plus luxueux paquebot du monde a
pris la mer et peut-on dire c'est le
chef-d'oeuvre de l'année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]